all right 64 was it not the first time
but I think it's been a while mr. Allen
chess all right um okay all right um
let's try the Sicilian let's see what we
get okay play this more than any other
it's late I see six okay so it was a
vigorously mo attack without d6 ECL code
beat 30 what do you do something
different right
85 moving the same piece twice now what
all right let's try this I did the
knight move just for some variety don't
allow the possibility for Bishop takes
Knight
additionally a6 could come with tempo if
the bishop does decide well I can't make
use of that square but I'll be putting a
question this Bishop soon and ah I
actually had to miscalculation first I
played the e6 thinking that if I did a
six the Bishop plate is c4 I can't do
that I should have done this right away
that was that was wrong of me to do this
move I should have thrown a question of
this bishop right away I still want to
do it but now the thing is the bishop
could come all the way back and white
remains much more coordinated by being
able to make use of f1 if I did a move
sooner it would have had to play to e to
where it gets in the way of both the
Queen and the rook so there's already an
inaccuracy
I'm also down with my development so
okay the bishop is still deciding to go
here I think you should just go to f1
going all the way back
there's no like some there's not gonna
be some pin over here that's going to be
an issue so I think now what do I do
I think I just step up one I'm going to
ctrl e five before I play here I'm
making a lot of pawn moves I violated a
lot of chess principles so far I like
this c3 move looking to get d4 in but
but but what okay just go for with this
I made a lot of pawn moves I moved a
piece twice in the opening things you
really shouldn't be doing too too much
of the very very early stages 86 however
did come with an attack against the
bishop so that's really not so bad
it's actually quite typical in the
Sicilian looking for expansion keeping
out if the night that it was on c3 it
rolls on might be five stuff etc so
Queen c7 as a follow up maybe I'm not
threatening to take on e4 by the way
because there is Queen a4 stuff
however after d4 how do I react in the
center it's a comes very important to
know how to react and I don't know if I
know how to react I think the first
thing I need to do is to take and then
press four okay we're not having that if
the pawn was on d4 I think I would first
consider taking and then pushing forward
important to first take as otherwise
takes Bishop takes there's maybe Forks
that White has with b4 so anyhow we're
not having that but eventually if
there's a pawn on d4 I think I want to
play d5 and if I 5 I want to play 94
post up on that Square we're not having
that however so this is a bit curious to
me to see this I'm gonna go what they
move that well I guess many of you could
have anticipated ha because it's his
only move right moving the piece with
the least amount of flexibility first
least amount of options first this guy
King King side castle b5 Bishop e7 Queen
c7 to indirectly control a 5 seems like
with the d3 why does
looking forward to something that's more
commonly seen in a Rilo Pez I don't see
another thing better than to just Castle
right away I think be 5 and then Bishop
d7 what's stopping me from doing that
not seeing it run forward I'm pretty
much caught up with my development I
don't know that you could really claim
one side being better than the other due
to a lead in development now let the
night is on d2 this earlier idea I had
of meeting d4 with this okay now if I do
that it's gonna be some issues isn't
there maybe there was a problem with
this yeah maybe I should have been more
concerned about being able to meet d4
with E 5 since this night was now is now
controlling deep controlling e4 and
making this maybe not the greatest thing
anymore as a response to a pond being
established on d4 I don't know if d5 is
good anymore like I do first I do this
move see now now I believe I'm going to
be encountering some problems let me
take here first I think I still might
have to go forward with this yeah I
think I still do this I better I better
do this otherwise I start getting kicked
around I don't think my knight has a
good square to go to anyhow there's um
again some inaccuracies the a6 move I
should have done it sooner and I should
have been more aware of once the knight
is controlling e4 you know maybe maybe I
don't have d5 is a great response
anymore I think it's okay
yeah actually I'm quite alright with
this I think that's perfectly fine
it's very inconvenient for this night if
Knight takes pawn takes have doubled
pawns but this night doesn't have the
greatest place to go to does he he
retreat okay well he retreats and hits
the pond but I could develop and defend
and maybe I could stir up some trouble
somehow hopefully and fast somehow
hopefully and fast I could stir up some
trouble if Knight takes pawn takes maybe
I could be getting at this pond a bit
easier I guess just Bishop here or do I
take no gonna do this I haven't this is
a bad Bishop so maybe I should be
welcome maybe I should be welcoming this
Knight captures so that my bishop can
actually be making use of d5 at some
point that would be a nice home okay I'd
have no choice I should have been in
pre-move mode without and I think now
well what piece is unprotected this guy
that's the one I'm gonna put pressure on
so now what do you do this is very
difficult to defend the knight place
here I could take it and then there's a
problem isn't there
structural damage knight b3 Knight takes
pawn takes as otherwise Queen takes is
met with rook takes looking more
long-term okay I don't want to allow
this Knight to play here so let's get
him off of the air get him out of there
before he's too big of a problem in
deciding what type of flight square to
make I'm going to go with g6 so that my
king could go to a dark square and so
that there's no opportunity for this
bishop to control that flight Square and
is there really a big thing here there
is okay that's just dropping this what's
the trick no trick I'm not seeing it
it takes pawn I'm just this is just but
he's basically on his way he might have
wanted to just go here even if there
wasn't a pond there no I double-double
rooks no back rank issues just yet
and maybe I don't even castle or just
get the Queen's off and then play Bishop
here Queen takes Queen rook takes the
rook is very active I play here
oh you know I'm just gonna meet threats
that my opponent has on me play rook
here I'm missing anything what about
even on time rip takes just rip takes
and now before I was saying before i was
saying g6 but now I'm saying g5 because
I want my king to be able to get to this
pawn my King gets here that's a problem
it's a big problem okay it stopped okay
play here
I really would I would like to get rid
of this pun and well I'm gonna do it
this way so just so I could get my King
in a strong position in the center my
king is in a good spot my opponent's
king is in a good spot and now we're
gonna get rid of the LightSquared Bishop
sir are we actually like my LightScribe
bishop that was a that was a I'm not
quite sure what to do move all right
let's open this up
pawn punish pawn push okay my rook is
very active let's get some checks
against the King and there's some tricky
stuff if the rook takes the pawn there's
a problem do you see it okay we didn't
we didn't get to see it but there would
have been a problem with that who knows
what the follow-up would have been if
rip takes pawn quickly in the chat this
game is over good game
Allen chess quickly what is the
continuation that we did not get to
maybe see quickly tricky tactics what is
it
who's gonna be the first to get it I'm
not seeing it just yet alright let's um
flip this board and go back here
we'll see what that is at that very end
so okay um okay let's let's go Russell
emo yet many of you are getting it that
tact let me just got to the end real
quick if rook takes who is sending it
some people in the chat Brooks Brooks II
- what was - repeat oh sure no thanks
got it and Shadowfax and show shantae
and some others yes idea here being Rick
be to the King moves you take the bishop
and then follow up with the Bishop c4
this is if white took the pawn give a
check grab the bishop and then land a
fork but leave Bishop takes pawn would
have been available anyhow what went on
in this game a very atypical Knight a5
move I should have played a6 right now a
six right now to kick the bish up so
that the bishop can't make use of f1 and
it should have made should have gone to
f1 right here all the way back stay out
of the way the rook let the rook see e4
and how would that influence things
because right now I think well for one
you don't have to play d3 to defend this
pawn that's why I guess d3 was being
played here to support this pond but I
don't know if you should be going
forward with that I guess another idea I
wonder if you could really get away with
something like Bishop d3 and backing up
to C - it seems always a bit awkward to
obstruct one of your central pawns with
the minor piece but definitely come all
the way I'm pretty sure you should come
all the way back to F 1 instead of e2
okay so d3 you get your Bishop out you
get your night out and now you get
pushing in the center hmm well at this
point maybe you should try and get this
pond right away Knight takes pawn takes
go here right now I defend and then you
back your Bishop up well I mean this is
another reason your Bishop again it
could be already on f1 and this could
maybe already be a problem you see if if
you have more if you have better control
of efore what might be the implications
of that it might mean that I'm not able
to just sit around with my knight on e4
like I was able to do in the game and
maybe I would then if your rook again
has site of efore directly I may be
forced into taking on d2 and helping you
develop your queen and then it's like my
bishop is very ugly it's uh it's not
it's not a good piece at all in the game
again I was able to make use of d5 but
only because I was able to allow my
knight to sit on e4 and after the
capture d5 was vacated so is really
everything being pointed at this the
bishops placement it might be or at
least many and many at many points right
here I don't think black has any trouble
at all this is this is actually just
turning out to be a big problem for
white because he's a liability
he's not I'm ready to take the pawn and
defend here if it's ever attacked again
you go back to f1 I'm just taking so I
guess you have to just take with the
pawn and maybe well I guess it I guess
it's just bad news no matter how you
slice it
I could I could pile up on this pond
with Queen B for a very active post
right in front of isolated pawns a good
home hitting at d4 so the suggestion is
really coming all the way back first for
me for not playing a6 right away for not
playing a6 right now and for white to
really just go back
home in a sense to f1 go back to that
home rank and then I like this c3 d4
idea then you don't have to what did you
end up doing in the game want another
way to look at it look at the look at
the journey you're deep on took it went
to d3 one two and three moves later
played to d4 I think you get that in in
one shot and save yourself a move and
stay out of the way of your rook on the
e-file by playing the f1 but as it stood
we ended up in a time scramble endgame
area and I don't know really who stands
better if we had more time at the end
here but yeah okay good game
Allen chess